uh happy thursday everybody yesterday
106 degrees a lot of times in the summer
heat you know you'll find that your
appetite just kind of wanes a little bit
we had a very hot day yesterday we're
going to trade that heat back for more
humidity temperatures right now having a
tough time cooling down we're down into
the upper 80s even stuck at 90 degrees
nellis the strip and near 90 in
henderson 63 in green valley humidity is
still near 40 percent dew points near 60
degrees so we got rid of a little
humidity and we got a whole lot of heat
in trade but now it'll be back again the
humidity is coming up the monsoon
moisture's surging our way under 80
degrees in kingman and thunderstorms
very close 97 in laughlin also showers
and thunderstorms are coming up 85 in
mesquite 78 indian springs and low 80s
for peru so yesterday 106 as we get the
increase in cloud cover and more monsoon
moisture temperatures will be down again
today down to 100 is what we're looking
for 104 is normal sunrise at 5 50. we'll
see those clouds with the early light
here and 7 43 is the sunset look at
today's record high 116
and that's not too unusual i mean july
we had some hot days they weren't
terrible august we're usually hot and
humid and then sometimes we get the
benefit of the rain so see the clouds
coming in nothing on the valley radar
yet but it's not going to take long look
at the convection the explosion of
thunderstorms over in arizona this
morning so we talked about that surge of
monsoon moisture and man is it coming up
fast
it's really swinging around but new
mexico arizona and western and
southwestern new mexico arizona getting
a lot of thunderstorm activity right now
along with lightning and heavy rain now
this is going to keep coming and as it
does it is going to produce some heavy
rain makers there are
flash flood watches posted for areas
west of las vegas over in tanay county
esmeralda counties and over into inyo
county even the mountains of san
bernardino could get some very heavy
rain today and then those thunderstorms
are going to swing north but we're not
going to rule out that we'll get some
isolated thunderstorms that could also
bring brief heavy downpours for the
valley today we have at least a 40
percent chance of some good
thunderstorms today let's get back to
talking about wildfires there is a
another big wildfire burning east of
portland
this wildfires in wasco county over 10
000 acres look how dry the grass and the
vegetation up there a lot of wind there
are red flag warnings for high wind and
low humidity up in the northern rockies
for areas a little east of here but boy
oregon's really getting it with the heat
recently and the wind as well more heat
across the southern plains and big
thunderstorms around areas where they've
already had so much trouble with
flooding over the last few weeks st
louis getting big thunderstorms this
morning 100 degrees for us we'll be down
in the 90s starting tomorrow an even
greater chance of thunderstorms that
could lead to flooding tomorrow then we
take a little break over the weekend
temperatures back up to 101 sunday and
another surge of monsoon moisture with
thunderstorms next week as kiddos are
heading back to school